It's my pleasure to be the chair for this session, which is
on single-cell multi-omic technologies to understand genotype and
phenotype relationships. And
I'll kick things off with the first talk, and that'll be
followed by
Charles Gewirtz and Andrew Attie.
I don't have any disclosures that are relevant to the stuff that I'm talking about
today, but I just wanted to mention some of the SABs that I serve on,
just to be transparent.
So first I'll talk about some of our efforts to develop single-cell DNA and
RNA sequencing methods
to understand how mutations and copy number alterations lead to phenotypic changes
in cancer cells.
Chuck will be giving the second talk on high-content single-cell multiomics to
resolve molecular determinants of cancer cell phenotypes.
Chuck has been working in the single-cell DNA field for quite a long time on
hematopoietic cancers and has founded a company,
BioScribe, which many people use and collaborate with these days.
And then Andrew's going to give the third talk on advances in single-cell DNA
methylation and multi-omic technologies analysis.
And Andrew's really a pioneer in technology development, especially around
combinatorial indexing methods and studying epigenomics
both in cancer and in normal development and
neurological systems.
So we have a really great lineup of talks today.
I'm excited to hear from all of them.
So just to introduce the topic a little bit, this is a PubMed search I did for
single-cell sequencing papers. It's a field that's just been growing tremendously
over the years. It's a very common practice in research today,
and there's a severely outdated analysis I did of papers in the
field from 2015, but I think they're still about correct
today. The cancer field is still a very large one where these technologies are
being applied a lot, as well as fields like neuroscience, developmental
biology, and other areas like immunology.
So one of the limitations for single-cell
technologies is that although many of them have been commercialized now, we have
great methods to do single-cell DNA sequencing, especially copy number analysis,
but also to look at mutations. We have great methods to do single-cell RNA
sequencing that are scalable, high throughput,
10x genomics, also combinatorial indexing methods.
And many of these have been commercialized now as well, Pars Bio, Scale Bio as
well,
and even great methods to do single-cell epigenomics, DNA methylation, ATAC
sequencing, CUT&Tag methods. Most of these are unimodal.
There's a few now that have been commercialized, like there's a DNA and
ATAC-- Sorry, RNA and ATAC method from 10x Genomics.
But the majority of methods are unimodal, and they do great.
But that's a limitation because a lot of times we do want to understand how these
modalities relate to each other and lead to biological phenomenon.
So I just wanted to brainstorm a little bit about some of the questions we can ask
if we have really great multimodal technologies,
and the biology that we can study with them, especially in cancer.
So one of the first ones is really just understanding the central dogma of biology.
How do things like mutations and copy number changes result in changes in the
transcriptome or the epigenome,
affect protein translation and protein abundance, and then ultimately affect
the phenotype of the cell?
Another one is really to understand the relationship between the genotype
and the phenotype. And so how genetic alterations like mutations and copy number
can lead to changes in the cell's proliferation, properties, the
cancer hallmarks like EMT or invasion, hypoxia migration.
And so really if we can get multiple measurements from the same cell at scale, we
can understand these relationships.
Another important question has to do with cancer evolution, and we
know that we can reconstruct genetic lineages of cancer cells
and understand how different subclones evolve in the tumor over time.
But a real question is whether these phenotypes that we just mentioned in cancer,
are they encoded by the genetics or which ones are plastic?
We know things like EMT, for example, doesn't have a lot of known genetic
mutations or copy number alterations.
And so with this type of data, you can reconstruct lineages, map phenotypes onto
those lineages, and understand about plasticity in cancer.
Another important question is to understand kind of cis and trans impacts of
genetic alterations on things like gene expression.
In other words, when you have a copy number gain or loss or
even a mutation,
how does it impact the genes in those regions, and how does it also
impact genes across the genome? And how
can that affect regulation that affects the phenotype of the cell?
And so by looking at things like subclonal alterations in cancer, you can
start to get and study at some of these relationships.
Another one is understanding cells of origin in cancer.
So in many cancers, we don't actually know what the cell of origin is.
It's usually an epithelial cell, or in sarcomas, it might be another type of
cell. But with these methods, we can link the
programs of the cells directly to their genetic profiles, and that can teach us a
lot about
cells of origin. In breast tissues, we have three different types
of epithelial cells, luminal cells that form the lumen inside, the myepithelial
cells around the outside. And there's big questions about whether these give rise
to ER positive or negative breast cancers, which are the two main subtypes.
And a final question that I think we can address here is are there DNA
alterations in non-cancer cells?
In other words,
can you acquire mutations, copy number events in cells like
stromal cells or immune cells, and can they also help promote a cancer
progression? This is also very understudied in the cancer field.
There was a nice paper by Fuqiao Tang's group not too long ago showing that
fibroblasts in colorectal cancer often have this chromosome 7
amplification across patients. And they suggested that that might contribute to
more of a CAF-like phenotype that promotes cancer progression.
But for most cancers, we really don't know whether these alterations exist or
not and whether they promote cancer
progression.So, some of the first
techniques that were described to look at DNA and RNA in a cell, which I'll talk
about a lot in my presentation today, included things like GNt-seq.
This was by Thierry Voet's group, and DR-seq from Alex van Oudenaarden.
These important studies showed that it's technically feasible to
measure both modalities from a cell, but they were quite difficult to perform.
GNt-seq, you have to physically separate DNA and RNA from a cell before
amplification.
DR-seq, the bar coding is quite difficult. So they are low throughput.
They were expensive and very high costs, but they were pioneering for the
time. This is really around the time that the first single-cell DNA and RNA methods
were being described. There have been another series of
papers, work from Fuchou Tang.
Also more work from Thierry Voet's group.
Also DEFENSEC from Peter Sims' group, and some methods like
GOT from Dan Lundahl's group. And these are all methods that allow you
to look at DNA and RNA simultaneously in cells.
They still have some challenges. For example, DEFENSEC doesn't completely lyse
chromatin, so the complexity of the DNA is low.
GOT is really looking at mutations in transcriptomes, so that's affected a lot
by expression, RNA editing. And these methods are still relatively low
throughput. So there's still a lot of work to be done here, I think, to be able to
scale this up.
And so we really want to be able to scale these co-measurements up,
have better high-quality DNA library complexity that you can look at, better
genomic resolution, and then streamlined protocols that you can perform in the same
reactions or tubes so that they can be adapted for micro droplets or nanowells.
In my own lab, over the years, we've developed a lot of unimodal technologies.
So, starting with some of the early single-cell DNA sequencing methods that use
things like DOP-PCR,
methods that use things like MDA to look at mutations across the genome
at base pair resolution. We've also developed some methods to do single-cell RNA
sequencing. And then more recently, we've been using tagmentation chemistries to
look at single-cell DNA alterations. But they've all been unimodal so far.
More recently, we've tried to really develop multimodal methods,
and so we have a few methods developed now that are in
papers that are published or coming out.
One of them is WELL-DAC that looks at DNA in ATAC.
It does essentially two rounds of tagmentation, one with the chromatin ATAC, one
with it removed. This is now on bioRxiv.
I won't talk about this today, but you're welcome to look at this paper.
Another paper called WELL-DR or WELL DNA and RNA sequencing.
This was published in "Cell," and this is one of the first methods we
published to do the chemistries. It's a DNA first chemistry, so we
do tagmentation of DNA initially, followed by the RNA chemistry.
And today, I'll talk a lot about a new method called ARCH-DR or archival
DNA and RNA sequencing. And this is a new method where we can look at copy number
alterations, mutations, and RNA simultaneously in thousands of cells at the same
time.
So I won't talk about the WELL-DR study too much because it's already published.
It does allow you to scale up things quite a bit.
In nanowells, you can look at thousands of cells, usually about 1,800 to 2,000
cells per experiment. It did have very good genomic DNA
resolution. The RNA quality, I would say, is moderate, and so that's something that
we've been improving on a lot.
But it requires fresh cells, so that's quite a limitation for clinical samples.
It can't really look at mutations.
And yeah, as I mentioned, the RNA quality was kind of moderate.
So, today, I'll be talking about the new method, ARCH-DR, and
how we apply this to study esophageal cancer.
And this is a collaboration and work that was done through Rui Yi, a
postdoc in my laboratory, Kyler Wang, former postdoc, now a PI
in Shanghai, and Steven Lin, who is an oncologist in the
Radiation Oncology Department.
So esophageal cancer or EAC is one of the most
common forms of esophageal cancer, esophageal adenocarcinoma.
The major risk factors are acid reflux that you get, as well as smoking, alcohol
use, and there's about 21,000 new cases per year in the US.
The five-year survival rate is only 20%, so we really need better treatment
modalities here. And, interestingly, it has a much higher incidence in
China, Iran, and Central Asia.
These cancers are interesting from a genomic perspective because they have lots of
extrachromosomal DNA.
We also see more intratumor heterogeneity and aneuploidy in these cancers and many
other types. And there have been some driver genes identified, including things
like CDKN2A, KRAS, ERBB2, TP53,
EGFR, and PIK3CA.
So the questions we're interested in studying here is really what's the cell of
origin for EAC, and
is there switching of cell lineages during cancer and clonal evolution?
Which are the ecDNAs that arise, and how are they inherited through the genetic
lineages? And which driver and copy number and
mutational events lead to gene expression differences?
And finally, are different phenotypes inherited in the genetic lineages, and which
are plastic?
So, some of the technical challenges then is that this extensive intratumor
heterogeneity exists, and so, we need to use single-cell DNA methods.
We want high genomic resolution, so we can detect really focal events that are
ecDNAs that might only be a few hundred kilobases.
We need a co-assay method to look at DNA and RNA, and we want to be able to
link the cellular epithelial lineages and identities to the genotypes.
And we also want to be able to look at frozen and FFPE materials because fresh
materials are not always available and don't have long-term clinical outcome data
available. And we want to look at mutations and copy number events.
So in this method that we've developed, archival DNA and RNA sequencing,
we can look at RNA species, copy number alterations, and
mutations all at the same time in the same cells.
We've done a lot of work to look at QC metrics, and we've shown that things like
overdispersion is very low, similar to our previous methods
and things like DLP from Saurabh Jha's group.
The breadth of coverage is very high, so similar to what we see in our unimodal
methods for single-cell DNA sequencing.And for our RNA-seq, we see very
high gene counts, which is great, higher than what we see for
10x version three,
and much better than our older Well DR chemistry or what we see with Defense EQ.
This is just an example of a human tumor sample where we took the same tissue,
we made a cell suspension, we snap-froze the tissue, and we embedded it in FFPE,
and then we ran the same assay on all three samples.
And at least at the cell type level, you can see that the cell types overlap very
well by the fixation method or preservation method, and
it suggests that we're still getting a really great RNA quality from these tissues,
even despite
fixing them or freezing them.
So in this study, we looked at 12 patients.
We dissociated the fresh tissues, we ran ArcDR, and then
we were able to look at RNA copy number and whole exome mutations at the same
time. We looked at about 34,000 cells in total with these
co-measurements and investigated some of the questions that I mentioned earlier.
Just looking at the RNA data, you can see that we typically see that the patients
have patient-specific clusters.
That's largely due to copy number alterations, which create gene dosage effects
since every patient has kind of a different overall global transcriptome profile.
In the other cell types, we see that they overlap quite a lot between patients, so
that's good.
So first, we wanted to look at the different cell lineages.
And so in esophageal cancer, the three major lineages are
esophageal, there's actually two separate ones, gastric, and then
intestinal, we have three different types.
We leveraged some data from the Human Atlas projects for the GI as a
reference, so we can really distinguish all these different lineages very well.
And then in our own data, we saw that the patients clustered a
lot by the lineages, which were different across different patients, as shown over
here.
And this plot over here shows you that within one patient, there typically isn't a
single lineage. You see one patient will often have multiple lineages that are
present. And I'll show that in a few slides after this as well.
So interestingly, when we look at copy number data from a single patient, this is
one of the patients here,
we can look at all genomic alterations and identify subclones in this heat map.
In this particular patient, we had a separate subclone that was very different,
didn't share any of the copy number alterations and really looked like an
independent lineage. Now, when we looked at the mutations, actually found that
there were a few shared variants, although that lineage down here has a lot of
mutations that are different as well.
And in a subclonal tree, you can see that that divergent lineage or
independent lineage was kind of out here, an outbranch, and it had gastric
epithelial cell type, really looking like a different cell type.
On the other hand, the other subclones were over here, and they have kind of
intermixed lineages,
as indicated in the colors here, some of the intestinal populations over here,
and some of the esophageal populations over here.
But interestingly, when we see this in patients, there are about three or so.
When there's a divergent genetic lineage, it typically has a different cell of
origin as well. But as you can see, most of the subclones have multiple lineages
associated, suggesting that there's pretty high cellular plasticity
here for the epithelial markers.
Next, we looked at extrachromosomal DNA events, and in EAC,
we see quite a lot of these. The easiest thing is if you look at this line plot
down here, you see these very thin lines. These are high copy number events.
Interestingly, in this patient, there were two separate subclones.
One subclone had high EGFR amplification, the other one had high ERBB2
amplification, and that was indicated in the lineages here.
These subclones over here have ERBB2, these have EGFR.
If we look at gene expression, it correlates very well.
The subclones on the top have high ERBB2, and they have low
EGFR. And on the other lineage, they have low ERBB2, high
EGFR.
This is actually important because in the ecDNA field, it's still
unclear how these things are inherited in genetic lineages and whether it kind of
follows
what you would expect for a kind of mitotic
inheritance and segregation, or whether it's just random dispersion.
And so we really see that it does follow the segregation pattern.
We use methods like Amplicon Architect to reconstruct and assemble the
reads across the subclones and show that these are really circular species that
exist at a high copy number level in the cells.
Interestingly, we looked at the gene expression for different ecDNAs and
overall across all the patients.
And we found that for ecDNAs, the gene expression really saturates around 20
copies or so. You kind of see this linear increase with copy number as you go from
zero to 20. But once you approach 20 copies, it's fairly flat.
And so that allows us to understand and interpret that
perhaps cells just can't tolerate really, really high levels of ecDNA or
expression.
We also looked more globally at the correlation of gene expression
and copy number events. And we found that overall, there's about
51% of the genes that when you have a copy number gain or a copy number loss,
follow that pattern. And there's about 50% genes that don't agree with increased
expression or lower expression in copy number regions.
And based on that, we can classify genes into dosage sensitive or dosage
insensitive. And it's interesting to look then at a lot of the EAC driver
genes. Some genes like CDKN2A really has this
linear increase and gene dosage relationship, as well as
KDM6A, another event that's common in EAC.
But other genes, even ones that you in other cancers you know correlate a lot with
expression, in EAC like MYC doesn't seem to correlate with copy number
and increased expression levels. And that's also true for ARID1A.
And so we can classify all the genes based on whether the data is sensitive or
insensitive.
Next, we can also look at mutations.
And so mutations, it's also very interesting to understand the relationship with
gene expression.
Overall, these were the variants that we found and looked at.
We found that about 20% or so correlate with differences that
happen in gene expression.
And so we're showing you some examples here.
So interestingly, if you look at P53, we
compare wild type subclones versus mutant subclones.
The ones with the mutations have much higher gene expression levels.
But if you look at copy number in EAC, actually, there's no
difference.CDKN2A as well, when you find a mutation, there's a
very high difference in gene expression.
And then SMAD4, this is an inactivating loss of function mutation.
And so when you have this one, you see that
actually the expression goes way down, whereas there's no difference in copy
number. So overall, we found that about 20% of somatic mutations actually
had an impact on gene expression, which is different, of course, than what we see
for copy number.
Finally, we looked at these questions around genetic hardwiring and
plasticity in the lineages. And so what we do is we take all the single cell
profiles. We can take a consensus and look at different subclones as shown over
here, and then we can reconstruct a copy number lineage.
This is with a method called MEDIC2, which is based on copy number events.
And it has a bifurcation here into these two major lineages, and then within those,
there's differences in the subclones.
And so we found that some genes like MDM2 are very heritable, so you see them only
express high in one lineage. This is MYC over here.
It's also expressed mostly in one lineage, but other genes like cyclin E1,
you can see that it's expressed across the lineages.
And so we would call this a more plastic type of gene.
So we can do this across all the patients.
So we can look at pathways now and signatures that follow the genetic lineage or
are independent of it. And so we find some pathways
and signatures that seem to be very genetically heritable.
In this case, I'm showing you this example of wound healing, where you can see it's
very constrained to the genetic lineages across multiple patients,
and following here, also this lineage.
And other phenotypes, things like mitoses.
We also saw DNA repair. These look to be much more plastic, and so
you can see that they exist across multiple lineages.
It's high over here as well and here as well across the lineage.
And so, those seem to be much more plastic or maybe more transient
programs that occur within lineages and are not always tied directly to
genetic events.
And then finally, we looked at the non-cancer cells.
And so, in this study, we were looking across all the cell types
that are essentially not the tumor cells or aneuploid cells.
And we found that there are chromosome X losses, and they're very
common, mostly in the T cells. We don't see those in other cell types.
And of course, we looked at this mostly in the female patients, where there's two
intact chromosomes. Interestingly, when you lose the X chromosome, there's really
no difference in expression. That's probably because you're losing that inactivated
allele that's been inactivated by Xist.
In contrast, for the Y chromosome loss, when we see that
male patients lose the Y chromosome, there's a big difference in the
expression of genes. And we can also map both of those
events very granularly to different cell states.
We did this in T cells, and so we see some different distributions across the
T cell populations, but actually Y and X are occurring pretty much across all
of the T cells. And I think the loss of Y chromosome is very interesting.
There's been more attention to this paid recently in the cancer field, showing
that sometimes loss of Y chromosome can affect cancer
progression and also T cells in patients.
So, to summarize this data, we developed a
high-throughput method that's compatible with fresh, frozen, and FFPE materials.
It's pretty scalable. We can look at thousands of cells.
We find that even though EACs have this clonal origin, so at the
genetic level, they really start from just a single cell.
However, they're able to switch, and they're very plastic during progression in
terms of the lineages they represent from the expression level.
ecDNAs are common. They're segregated, usually in genetic lineages.
And we see that they saturate in expression around 20 copies.
And about 51% of the genes are dosage sensitive, so they correlate with gene copy
number, but many genes are also not.
And about 20% of mutations result in expression changes that we can see in
the single cells.
And so the EAC patients have both plastic and genetically inherited genes.
And as we look at more patients, I think this will give us a better understanding
of events that are caused by genetic differences versus non-genetic differences.
And just on my last slide here and to set the stage for the next talks.
Really, I think the ultimate goal here is to be able to measure many modalities
from single cells. Hopefully, in the next five to 10 years, we'll get there.
This is a fast-moving area. So in addition to DNA and RNA,
which I mostly talked about today, we'd like to be able to look at epigenetics,
look at methylation, ATAC, Hi-C conformations,
certainly protein abundance modifications as well.
And I think what's missing a lot too right now is imaging data.
So if we have ways to do high cellular imaging, we can also get morphometrics, look
at subcellular differences as well,
and to be able to do this all modalities at high scale.
And then we can really learn a lot about cancer phenotypes, cancer hallmarks,
how these things ultimately interact together to affect
cancer and cancer progression, and then how we can target that to improve cancer
treatment and diagnosis.
So I think I'll end it there. And
a big thanks to everyone in my lab that did this work.
I especially want to recognize the work from Rui Yi, who
did a lot of the technology development here, Kyler Wang, and our
collaborators in the clinic, especially Stephen Lin for this project.
And I think I have a little bit of time, so I'll take some questions. Thank you.
Thank you for the presentation. John Schatz, University of Miami.
I'm wondering, when you looked at the non-tumor cells, if you did
any analyses of the state of the
microenvironment relative to the tumor
genotype/phenotype relationships that you established?
For example, loss of antigen presentation machinery leading to depletion
of CD8 T cells, that sort of thing.
Yeah. So with this RNA data, we can look at all these cell states in
quite granular detail. And so I was just showing some examples
for the X and Y chromosome losses that occurred.
And-We see a lot of changes at the RNA
level, obviously. So, for fibroblasts, we see a lot of CAFs
in tumor, in endothelial cells, we saw a lot of tumor endothelial cells.
But we don't always see genetic events that are associated with those
phenotypes.
So far, I think, at least the data we have in EAC doesn't show a strong
correlation with those tumor-associated cell states and
genetic events that we have. But it may be cancer type specific.
Certainly, the work Fuchou Tang did in colon cancer showed that a very common
gain on chromosome 7, I believe it was,
leads to CAF states in those cancers.
So I think we have to look at a lot of cancers and try to understand,
and
see if there are genetic events that also drive things over in the stroma or the
immune cells.
Thank you.
Andrew?
Hey, Nick.
The gene dosage work is super cool.
Do you see instances where you have, in some
patients, gene dosage sensitivity and then others where it's not?
So, like a patient-specific, whether that gene is affected by dosage.
Yeah.
So those are really interesting questions, and I think what you're getting at is
differences potentially at the epigenetic layers that might be regulating those
things,
knowing your background.
But,
yes, no, we try to really classify things across
patients. So there was also a lot of patient variability, too.
I think we're missing the extra layer.
It'd be great to look at methylation or ATAC data that could help us
understand
those 50% of transcripts that are not correlated.
When I try to think about things more longitudinally, I imagine that there's a lot
of aneuploidy occurring early on in progression, and so at that time, probably gene
dosage is very highly correlated, I think, with the copy number events.
But cells have to respond. You can't tolerate thousands of genes being
upregulated or downregulated. And so I think that's where the epigenome comes in
and regulates things. And so by the time we see the tumor, which of course is after
millions and millions of cells, I think there's a lot of biology that's already
happened to try to do gene regulation and get these cancer cells into
their high fitness programs that lead to the expansion and everything.
But yeah, thanks for the question.
Thank you.
Over there.
Sandy Markowitz at Case Western. I'm wondering whether you
know in the instances where you're seeing sex chromosome
loss in T cells, is that specific to the T cells in the
tumor, or is it systemic?
That's a great question. We haven't looked a lot at many normal tissues.
We have seen these losses in several cancer types, so I
think we would have to look a bit more at normal tissues and see if
these events are common as well.
Yeah. So whether it's a cancer-specific phenomenon or whether it contributes to
cancer in some way, I think that
would be an interesting question.
Even though you lose the inactivated allele, I think there have been studies
showing that even when it just inactivates one of the X chromosomes, there can
still be gene expression that might be important, and so it's not like it's
completely inactivated. So yes, I think it'd be interesting to look
at normal tissues in more detail with methods like these.
And can you also comment on the state of
technologies for doing single-cell methylation
studies?
Yes. Actually, I think we'll be hearing a lot about that in the next
talk, so I'll save that for Andrew.
But
certainly, there's a lot of work been done in that area.
There's also some commercial platforms now.
ScaleBio, which was recently bought out by TenX Genomics, has a comet tail
indexing-based method. And I think you'll see a lot of new technologies being
developed, especially over the next year or so, that are coming out soon.
Thank you.
Hi. Yashvin Manickam from UCSD Medical Center. Great talk, Dr.
Navin. I was really interested in the slide you showed showing the
differences in pathway variation across cell lineages, and I was
wondering if you could speculate as to the effects of differential
cell proliferation and DNA repair on the distinct
lineages that you see across cell types in the study.
Yeah. To me, those programs make sense to some degree because, of
course, cells, they're going into cell
cycle, but then they're also going out and going into
G1 or G0. And
so it's a transient state. So I'm not surprised
that we see certain subclones that may be proliferating more and
others that are proliferating less, and that we can capture that.
Of course, there are genetic events that are associated with proliferation, like in
breast cancer, cyclin D amplification, RB1 mutations,
those things.
Those occur earlier on, typically, in cancer progression.
So that's not really what we're looking at here in terms of classifying things as
plasticity, because the lineages I show you are branching after the
MRCA. So you can think of it a little bit like the later stages of cancer
progression. But yes, and DNA repair as well.
Again, it's usually something that might be going on and
off and may have higher levels in certain subclones than others.
So, yes. But those are the programs that we see that, at least in
the subclonal data, seems to be a little bit more independent at that time in the
tumor from genetic events.
Yeah, it's very exciting work. And I think that the
slides you were showing with the correlation of specific mutations correlating with
gene expression is very exciting as far as expanding that into the multi-omics
scene, which I'm sure we'll get into in later talks. So yeah, thank you very much.
Great. Thanks. Maybe last question. Thanks.
Hi, Kara Maxwell from University of Pennsylvania.
So I was wondering if in your data, if you've looked to whether or not the ecDNA
load correlates with TP53 mutation status or expression levels yet?
Yeah. Great question. We didn't look in detail at the correlation, I think.
I think that's interesting. A lot of these patients do have P53 mutations.
We do have that data. It might be something that we can go back and look at some
more. So thanks for the suggestion.
All right. Great. Thank you. So, let me introduce our next speaker then.
It's Charles Gewirtz. He's coming from Stanford University.
And his talk is High Content, Single-Cell Multi-omics Can Resolve Molecular
Determinants of Cancer Cell Phenotypes.
Thanks, Nick. So, great first talk to set the stage here,
and I'll continue with a lot of the same kind of themes.
But I do have one disclosure, which is relevant to what I'll be presenting.
So the way I'd like to frame this is the field's split in a couple
different areas right now. So,
as you'll hear from Andrew, he's developed technologies where you can do lots and
lots of cells. But typically, because of sequencing
cost, you have to choose, am I going to do a lot of cells, or am I going to do a
lot of the genome? And so we've focused on doing small numbers
of cells, but trying to get very, very high content
information. I think the field, in general, is moving towards
lots of cells at very high content.
And that's really, I think, going to be driven over the next couple of years by the
significant drop in sequencing costs.
So my strategy, similar to Nick, I think, as well,
has been to really focus on the DNA first.
And so we're trying to make really the highest quality DNA
measurements from a single cell. And then on top of that, continuously
add layers, the transcriptome, epigenome, other things that Nick
mentioned.
And then use that same cell data to try and train models that can connect
genotype to phenotype.
So what do you get from going to single cell?
I get asked this question sometimes.
So there are very sensitive methods for looking in bulk, and you
can detect really rare variants in that.
But you don't know if they occur in the same cell.
You don't know the phylogenetic relationships.
You don't know the associated phenotypes with those, so connecting genotype with
phenotype is not possible. And then when you get down to the single cell, you can
actually do things like compute the number of mutations per cell,
look at signatures per cell, look at early versus late signatures, a
number of different things.
So how have we measured-- What's the most accurate ways of measuring mutations
in single cell? So this is work that's been going on for some time at the
Sanger, looking at normal cells. And they've developed protocols where they
isolate individual cells, they'll expand them over a month or two, and then when
they have enough cells, they'll sequence them,
and with that, be able to get very accurate numbers of
mutation calls. And you can see naive B cells, memory B cells, and they
can look at a person's age, how many mutations they acquire.
So this, I think, was a great review on somatic genomics.
And the thing that really struck me was when you look when they actually quantitate
the number of mutations in normal tissues, in the liver, we have
410 trillion mutations by the time we're 50.
Even in our brain, we've acquired across all our cells about 74 trillion
mutations. And so there's a whole level of genetic diversity that's
hidden there that we don't know about it.
So the issue, though, with
being able to do this type of study is that you're actually
selecting for specific cells that you can grow.
The phenotype can drift over time.
Some cells you can't grow at all. And so it's really quite limited in connecting
genotype to phenotype.
So the more direct way to do it would be to amplify the genome.
But the bottleneck for a long time has been the quality of the data you get back
when you go from one copy of the genome to thousands of copies, you need to make
a sequencing library. And as I'll show you, you typically get these biases where
you get regions of lots of coverage and other regions where you don't cover very
well at all. And so again, the issue's been poor
uniformity or coverage. That leads to changes in your single nucleotide
variant sensitivity. You get false positives introduced depending on which enzymes
you use. And there's really been lack of reproducibility,
which I think has limited the ability to scale to lots of cells.
You really need a very robust, reproducible chemistry to scale to
lots of cells as well.
So what we came up with in my lab, so the traditional workhorse has been this
method called MDA.
Generally, how it works is you have a random primer, you add Phi 29 polymerase,
it runs on for tens of kb, it has strong strand displacement
activity, and then it starts to amplify with branching structures in an
exponential manner. And what that does is it leads to this
high coverage of some regions wherever the primer's bound
first and low coverage of neighboring regions.
With PTA, we wanted to take advantage of the low error rate of
the polymerase and the processivity, the easiness of the protocol, but we
added irreversible terminators to the reaction.
And what that does is limits the processivity, slows the reaction
down, and then we end up displacing those, but we get small
amplicons that in theory would cover the genome in a much more uniform
manner. And so if you look at number of reads or amount of sequencing
and fraction of genome covered, in the initial paper, we compared to all the
other methods that had been out there at the time.
So you can see we're approaching what you would cover in a bulk sample
within a single cell.
And then when you look with MDA, as you walk across chromosome one, this is
the centromere, which isn't covered very well in both methods.
But you see, again, these peaks and valleys, which you'll get a lot of information
from here and very little from the things that are down there.
So with PTA, again, with the same amount of sequencing, same windows,
you can see we're covering the genome in a much more even manner, not as even
as bulk, but much more even, which improves our ability to
detect variants and do things like call copy number alterations.
And so using the bulk samples as the gold standards, we asked what
percent of mutations, germline variants, actually in this case,
in the single cells can we detect that were known to be in the bulk
sample as kind of the gold standard.
And so with PTA, we're detecting about 90% of variants, which is a significant
improvement over other methods.
And then the precision, which this was a few years ago,
things have actually improved significantly, but was kind of on par with
MDA. And so doing things like lowering the temperature and
adding things like deep variant models for variant calling has helped us improve
the precision quite a bit.
One thing to notice is methods that use a lot of PCR, so use a lot
ofthermostable polymerase, which has one to two orders
of magnitude higher error rate, you get lots and lots of false
positives as a result of that.
And so another important variable is looking at the allele frequency of
heterozygous variants. So you want to maintain the two alleles as even as
possible. And in a single cell, they should have an allele frequency around
50%. And this is one of the key features that's really enabled PTA
to be able to call heterozygous variants quite accurately
or variants quite accurately. And so you can see much better than the other
methods, we retain that allele frequency distribution of variants
that were known to be heterozygous in the bulk sample.
Again, compared to the other methods, you can see we don't see
that.
Again, not to belabor the point but the false positives we
see with PCR-based methods are much higher just due to
the copying and the heating.
One other interesting feature of PTA compared to MDA, so Qiagen is
MDA, and in this experiment actually was
Qiagen with terminators.
And just with the terminators, it changed the reaction and the kinetics in such a
way that the small mitochondrial genome
is able to
amplify much more efficiently
in the context of PTA compared to MDA.
And so that's relevant to mitochondrial genomes, but it's also
relevant to ecDNA, and Dan Landau presented some of his work
on ecDNA at the plenary session a couple of nights ago.
Also relevant to things like bacterial genomes.
So we've worked with a group at the Joint Genome Institute and shown we can
amplify and assemble much better single bacterial genomes as well.
So this method's been picked up by many groups now
including Peter Park and Chris Walsh, who've been doing single-cell sequencing of
neurons for some time. And so again, you can
see bulk, you can see MDA going across the genome, the dispersion.
And then you can see PTA, again, not bulk, but much better than
MDA.
They've quantitated this with the MAPD, so the lower
the better. Again, you can see PTA has lower MAPD
with much less variance. And then these are the heterozygous variants, the allele
frequency distribution. Again, you can see PTA much more centered
around 50%.
And so then we wanted to ask, what can we use this for?
And as a pediatric oncologist, typically go back to looking at
childhood leukemias.
So part of this story is that
when people have done bulk sequencing of childhood leukemias, they've kind of
concluded the genome's not very interesting.
It's pretty genetically silent. We only find
hundreds of mutations per genome.
And so there's really not much interesting there.
But what we did is we actually took single cells from leukemia samples.
We sequenced the bulk sample and then took single cells from each of those bulk
samples and then used SCAN2, which is the variant calling
tool that Peter had developed here to get very accurate
mutation numbers per cell. And we found each cell
actually has
2,000 to 4,000 mutations, where there's only less than
1,000 mutations on average detected in the whole bulk sample.
And then you imagine a child when they're diagnosed, they have about 100
billion leukemia cells. So you're missing about
2,000 mutations per cell, but that's
going across billions of cells. And so the genetic diversity there is
just much, much greater than we can detect with bulk sequencing.
We can then do things like look at signatures, whether they're single
cell-based or,
and then, as I'll show in phylogenies, you can also separate those signatures out
over time. In this case, we created three de novo signatures,
one which looks like SBS2 and SBS13 from these
samples, which are APOBEC signatures, which are known to
occur in this type of leukemia.
So the other thing we can start to do is look at different regions of the genome
and what's enriched for. So in this case, what we found was an
enrichment in intronic, exonic, and upstream
mutations
from the single cells. And so this suggests the
enrichment isn't as high for the upstream, but it suggests there are a lot of
mutations in regulatory regions upstream that we're really not looking at
right now that are important. And as I'll come back to, those could
be important when you connect DNA and RNA to be
able to connect a mutation to a change in expression in the
same cell.
And then I've been working with Dan Landau and Tamara as
well on this. They've built some phylogenies.
They used a totally orthogonal method to estimate the number of
mutations per cell.
These are normal cells. It looks like there's some pre-leukemia cells
here. But again, you can see in the 1,000 to 3,000 range, so
quite similar. These were actually different samples, but in the same range of
mutation numbers per cell.
And then we wanted to ask, getting to phenotype,
can we connect genotype to phenotype?
And in this case, phenotype is drug resistance.
So if we take cells, we expose them to chemo in vitro
or in patients. And in this case, what we did was
took samples before and after a month of treatment,
take the surviving clones, and then say which clones became enriched,
and can we learn what was different about them that enabled them to survive the
chemotherapy?
And so, again, for heme malignancies, patients
typically go into remission, but a number of a
significant percentage are MRD positive.
And so what we did was took a sample here, took a sample after
a month of treatment,
and then did whole genome sequencing on those, built phylogenies, and
asked how does the phenotype map onto the phylogeny?
To do this, we did index sorting, so we also recorded six surface
markersSo in each well, we know the expression of six surface
markers. We also have whole genome from them
and can put all of those together.
And so this is just showing you what you're missing in bulk.
So at diagnosis in bulk, there were two different
activating JAK2 mutations in this sample.
At day 29, they were a small percentage of the cells, so we didn't detect
any of those. At diagnosis, there was, looks like a clonal
copy number alteration on chromosome five
or six, and a subclonal chromosome alteration.
And then again, the copy number profile's flat at day 29
because the tumor cells are quite rare.
So when we sorted out the individual tumor cells, in each of
them we found one of the two, almost all of them we found one of the two JAK2
variants. But then we started to see different variants we didn't
detect in the initial bulk sample.
And then we saw a whole range of copy number alterations.
So in each one, we saw this founding event, this loss on
chromosome four.
We saw this other subclonal event that was restricted to this clone,
and then we saw a whole range.
This one was restricted to this clone, was the most common that we didn't
detect in bulk before. But then we saw many different copy number
alterations, mostly deletions, that we didn't see at all in the bulk
sample.
So we then had the ability to think about how do we integrate CNV surface markers,
SNVs,
and
then also, again, map pre- and post-treatment samples
and ask, going down the phylogenetic tree, which clones were
enriched for? So where do you see...
In these two clones in particular, we didn't see
them prior in any cells of those in the pre-treatment sample, but we
see those clones in the post-treatment make up significant percentages.
We didn't see a change in the major copy number changes.
But again, we saw these two clones that really stood out, and we have
coding SNVs here that were associated with those clones that weren't
detected prior that you would think are playing a role, or we would
hypothesize are playing a role in the resistance.
So we did some work with Dan on this as well, and Dan really developed this tool
called PATH,
where, again, this concept that Nick introduced, whether or not something's
heritable
or plastic. So is it randomly distributed on the tree,
or does it
associate with a specific clone, suggesting that genetic determinants within that
part of the tree are driving the phenotype?
And Dan and Josh developed a quantitative framework to really
measure that. And so
as a first case study, we have JAK2 mutation,
which we know is heritable, and then we have a copy number alteration, which we
know is heritable. We have something like sorting time, which we know should
not be heritable.
And we use those as controls, and then we looked at the surface markers we had
and said, "Which ones appear to be most heritable?"
And again, this was a first case. We only had six markers, so kind of limited
in what we could look at. But really the powerful part is the quantitative
framework for being able to do this on larger data sets.
And so the larger data set would be being able to do this with genome and
transcriptome. Again, being able to connect a really high-quality genome
with a high-quality transcriptome and ask the questions
that Nick introduced. How are the two interacting?
How does genotype influence phenotype?
How does the context of the genotype change
the consequences of it?
And so we developed Resolvome, which is a
single-tube reaction where you lyse the
cell. We do a reverse transcription first and
biotinylate it, and then we lyse the nucleus and do PTA,
and then separate the DNA and RNA after the amplification, and then do
paired sequencing. And so we're able to maintain the DNA quality with
that and then get
good quality RNA libraries as well.
So this was the first paper that came out, but a number have come out, several have
come out since then. So Joe Gleason was using this to do lineage tracing
within the brain,
and then look at the phenotypes of the cells in which he was doing lineage
tracing.
So Dan, you can look here in his preprint, but
has taken this to another level. So this is
on normal esophagus, but they've done 3,500 whole
genomes and transcriptomes, and so
built these phylogenetic trees of the normal esophagus.
And on top of that, we're able to find all sorts of oncogenic events that occurred,
could characterize which cell types they were in,
a whole range of things. So you compare that to what you would get with
just a single-cell RNA-seq readout, where you would just get cell identity and
maybe some differences between them.
I think this is a rich data set for mining
deep understanding of the
correlation or the cooperation of the genetics in the cell state.
So then lastly, methylation was brought up, so we've been adding methylation as
the next layer. I don't have a lot of detailed information
to present today, but I'll present to you some
data that looks very promising. So the idea is quite
straightforward. We have PTA, which can amplify the genome.
So what if we could specifically deaminate 5mc?
And so we found some enzymes that really like 5mc and don't
deaminate unmethylated cytosine, so they're marking the
methylated. And so we just treat with this deaminase, and
then we do PTA. And with that, we get the
conversion, and then we also get mutations as well.
And so this is
percent of CpG sites covered. These are different cells, single cells.
So you can see we're covering 90% of CpG sites.
With that, we've been developing deep variant models that can differentiate
methylation from variants using the context.But we
found 80% of CPG islands we
can call, and then we still have 90% of the genome left.
So we can then add
variants on 90% of the genome in addition to that, and then this
is a genome in the bottle cell line, so we have a really good gold standard, and
when we look at the correlation between the single cells and the genome in the
bottle,
you can see very good correlation.
So still early with this, but very promising and
exciting.
In the last minute,
as I mentioned, really excited about scaling to thousands of cells as the
sequencing prices drop. So for example,
Ultima has announced an $80 whole genome.
They do 30X whole genome. Most people using our technology do
a 10X whole genome, so that gets to $26 or $27
per genome.
And so at that rate, you can think about doing thousands of cells,
and really getting deep information if we had genome
transcriptome, and then we think we can do genome transcriptome and methylation
in the same cell as well. But number of other sequencing offerings,
so it will be interesting to see how we can really scale
as that limiting factor gets dealt with.
And so again, getting back to AI, I think just a couple take-home
points real quickly. So I think there have been a lot of things on
virtual cells, just looking at low content data,
perturb-seq studies in cell lines, and I think to
get really deep models of tissue, we need really deep
information and we need primary samples.
And so that's what we're working towards.
And again, the rare cells is what we care about, which are lost in
bulk. And so if you have a treatment-resistant cell, you can build
a phylogenetic tree, you can understand the context of it, you can layer on
phenotypic information. But ultimately, I think that
deep information is what's going to lead to biomarkers that are directed towards
the cells you really want to kill or
to-- because they're the cells that are actually going to determine the outcome of
the patient.
And so with that, I thank the organizing committee
again for the invitation and happy to answer questions.
Hey, Chuck. A really nice talk.
I was wondering if you could tell us a little bit more just about the
scaling things up. What are the challenges?
Are there any strategies you're thinking
about?
Yeah.
Because you have really wonderful data sets, very high quality, very deep
data.
But it'd be nice to scale things up if there's-
Yeah, no. It's something I've thought quite a bit about.
Typically, droplet-based approaches are
problematic for us because we have multi-step chemistry.
And so most droplet approaches are one or two steps, whether it's
10X or Mission Bio. And so those aren't really compatible.
The other thing is we like to have bigger volumes.
So having teeny, teeny volumes is, I think, problematic when you're trying
to amplify a whole genome.
And so the first step we've done is
really to make the chemistry so it's completely additive.
So you can't have cleanups as you go to high throughput.
So being able to have the chemistry tolerate a barcode within the chemistry,
which we've been successfully able to do.
There are other methods out there with combinatorial indexing is a powerful tool
for trying to do that. We've been thinking about ways to do that
but haven't come up with
a real solution. But I think the first thing is getting the chemistry so
it's deployable within a completely additive environment.
And then scaling. The plan we have right now
is working with HP. They have a--
or Tikan, they have a liquid dispenser that's based on
inkjet printing, and it can do teeny, teeny volumes, and it can
do 1536 plate. There are other challenges with that,
but I think we may have solved that.
But I think we'll be able to get to 1536 pretty quick.
But being able to scale to tens of thousands of cells is going to
take a little time.
But again, the sequencing cost. To me, if you look at doing
an exome capture, you want to do a methylome and exome capture, it almost
becomes cheaper at this point to do whole-genome sequencing.
And so
I think pushing-- And as the sequencing keeps coming
down, we can continue to ramp up the number of cells we look at.
Thanks.
And our next speaker is Andrew Addy from OHSU, and he'll be talking
about single-cell DNA methylation multi-omic technologies.
All right. Thanks.
Yeah. So, first, thanks for the invitation.
I'm excited to be here, especially in a technology session.
I get to talk about one of my core passions, which is technology development.
So it's going to be technology-heavy.
And talking about what motivated us to develop these technologies,
how we've gotten to where we're at now, and really what our current capabilities
are to look at DNA methylation and multi-omics.
Some disclosures which are relevant to
my talk today.
So first, DNA methylation, this is the property that I've really been pursuing the
most throughout my career.
And what's the motivation for that?
AndMany of you are aware, this is review, but
in mammalian genomes, DNA methylation is typically this
methyl group on the five carbon of cytosine bases in this CG or
CpG context.
We often represent it as kind of like these lollipops, and the CG
dinucleotide context is the rarest in the genome because it has this regulatory
role.
And typically 60% to 80% of these CG sites are methylated genome-wide in
a typical mammalian cell type.
Whereas the non-CG sites are
typically completely non-methylated.
There are some exceptions that I'll touch on a little bit later.
So generally, DNA methylation is associated with repression.
I like to think of it as this initial gatekeeper of genomic permissiveness,
where the DNA methylation patterns really dictate which regions
of the genome have the potential for activation.
So often, DNA methylation of a promoter isn't going to correlate well with
expression. It's a common kind of misconception and an over-assumption.
It really correlates with the capability of a gene to become
activated, that the next layers of epigenetic machinery, such as open chromatin,
actuating that open chromatin with a transcription factor to then lead to
active transcription. And because it forms this
real masking role of the genome, it really makes it the most basal layer
of epigenomic regulatory control.
So it's kind of that first layer of gene regulation when you're looking at the
whole spectrum of gene regulatory dynamics.
We know a lot about some of the nitty-gritty mechanisms of
how it works. DNMT1, for example, is the methylation
transferase that does maintenance.
So when you have a new cell division, it copies over the methyl groups at these CG
sites. And then we know Tet proteins can
target loci for removal of DNA methylation.
And then de novo deposition of methylation is with DNMT3A or 3B.
And many of you will recognize these genes if you study any
blood cancers,
whereas Tet2 and DNMT3A are two of the major top driver genes in
AML.
Which then brings us to the role of DNA methylation in development and
disease, where cancer genomes-- And
I have the title of this slide is "DNA methylation is almost always altered in
cancer." I have yet to find a paper that's really studied DNA
methylation in cancer and has not found significant alterations.
And pretty frequently across a broad spectrum of cancers, you get this
hypomethylation phenotype, where large swaths of the genome end up being
hypomethylated and a reduction in that methylated level.
This can lead to things like retrotransposable element activation, which can then
lead to genome instability,
or hypomethylation of promoters that can lead to activation
of oncogenes. And more broadly, this really makes a lot of
sense with cancer because you get global hypomethylation, which then leads to this
reduction of that filter of regulatory control and repression on the
genome that gives a lot more pathways that are available for activation.
Cancer cells want to adapt and evolve, and removal of that
methylation kind of frees things up to enable them to explore those other
pathways and increase the cell state plasticity and ability to
adapt to external extrinsic pressures.
It's also a massive signal for cell-free DNA.
If you've looked at a lot of the work from GRAIL, for example, you see a lot of
cell-free DNA methylation that's being used for diagnostic purposes.
So like other properties, this is cell type specific, so it really
requires single-cell resolution to enable
looking at it and understanding this property.
But it's been traditionally much more difficult to look at methylation than
some of these other properties.
A lot of this comes down to the conversion approach.
So like what Chuck was saying, there's multiple steps that are required
to do this conversion, whether you're doing the traditional method where you
convert all cytosines to uracil and then methylated cytosines retain
their cytosine identity,
or flipping it with some of these newer chemistries
with methylcytosine-specific deaminases.
It still requires multiple steps, harsh chemicals, and it makes it
trickier to enable high-throughput single-cell technologies.
As a result, most techniques previously have been developed where it's single
cell, single well.
And some of these can produce great quality data, but it is inherently lower
throughput. And there's a place for low throughput, high coverage, as Chuck was
just showing. We're shifting things in a different direction.
We tend to do a little lower coverage, but much higher throughput, and it's just
not amenable with these approaches.
Though,
there is an exception. This method, SNm-C-seq from Joe Ecker,
who's at San Diego at the Salk Institute, who's really a pioneer in the
methylation space.
They just brute forced it with automation.
And here's an example from one of their studies from the BRAIN Initiative.
Over half a million cells that are really high coverage, high-quality
methylomes. But when you look at what it took to generate this data set,
it's almost 5,400 384 well plates with a large
portion of those actually 384 well column cleanups.
So just in plasticware alone, that's pretty inhibiting for most groups.
And I'm not saying this to take away from the paper.
I want to emphasize just the amount of work that went into producing this beautiful
atlas.
But I can't do that. Most labs don't have the storage space for that much
plasticware. So that's motivated us
to develop our technology, SKY-Met.
And this is a combinatorial indexing approach.
So we do two tiers of cell barcoding, the first being
tagmentation using indexed adapters.
We then pool these intact nuclei together, split them out, and then append a
second barcode. So this is the multi-tier barcoding.
So you can see in the kind of bottom well of this
examples here. There's multiple cells in the well, but they each have
unique barcode combinations, and it's that combination that gives us our unique
index.
So for methylation, though, if we wanted to do this where we do
in situ tagmentation, the first challenge is that this is the first
step for single-cell ATAC-seqSo you're only going to be getting reads
specifically at open regions of chromatin, which we don't really care about
with methylation. We want to get those regions, but we want to get the regions
where it's actually repressed.
So you're almost exclusively going to get hypomethylated regions in these open
chromatin loci. So we developed a strategy where we take our intact
nuclei and then actually remove and deplete these
nucleosomes across the genome to provide genome-wide access for this
transposase enzyme. So we can get genome-wide coverage.
So it's essentially ablating that ATAC-seq signal and getting uniform coverage
across the genome.
We initially applied this for single-cell whole-genome sequencing, and this is an
example where we identified some subclones in pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma,
and
showed that we could take that strategy.
But one of the challenges here, and one of the things that we've really wanted to
move forward with in my lab more and more is making these technologies more
accessible. No one was doing this technology when we published it, and the reason
is because you can't get these reagents.
You had to home brew, custom make a lot of the reagents, which is really a
barrier for a lot of research programs.
So not too long ago, we wanted to ameliorate this
and find a strategy that makes it much more accessible.
So to that end, we adapted our nucleosome disruption approach and made it so it's
compatible with the 10x Genomics single-cell ATAC-seq workflow.
So you can use that off-the-shelf kit with our pretty simple, straightforward
approach for nucleosome disruption to enable you to get single-cell
whole-genome sequencing in really high throughput.
Now, I also want to note this is kind of apples and oranges compared to what
Nick and Chuck were talking about.
This is lower coverage. It's not deep coverage.
You can't really do SNP profiling with this, but you can get copy number profiling.
And we applied it to this control cell line and then pancreatic
cancer as well.
So can we apply this
nucleosome disruption approach to get genome-wide methylation using our techniques?
And indeed, we can. The first version of this
was developed by Ryan Mulqueen, who's now a post-doc in Nick's group.
This was definitely a proof of principle.
It was a brutal, I think, 16-hour protocol with no stopping points and
not super robust, but it was that initial step that showed that it was
possible. And then we since did a lot of optimizing with
Ruth in my program to develop a really robust, really high
coverage, high throughput single-cell DNA methylation
technology that we're really proud of its really robustness and ability to be able
to be applied to even tricky tumor samples.
And then since then, we've scaled this up with our latest version.
This one has three levels of cell barcoding.
And as an example Vignet data set, we produced 140,000
single-cell methylome
data set in the human cerebral cortex.
The total library was over 600,000 cells, but we just
selectively sequenced a subset of it,
which is kind of a nice aspect of it.
It works with different conversion methods, and as well
it's compatible with different sequencing platforms.
We did a lot of this on Ultima because it was a
more cost-effective option for us. So most of the data was Ultima.
And then we have a multi-omic version that I'll touch on a little bit at the end.
But I do want to make a quick plug for our single-cell methylation analysis tool
called AMETHYST.
One of the things-- and this is developed by Lauren Rouleau, who's staying in my
lab. There's a GitHub with lots of tutorials, and the goal of
this was really to make it a kind of one-stop shop for single-cell DNA methylation
analysis.
Our goal here was to
get the analysis tools in the hands of the biologist that's doing the data.
So to that end, we really put a lot of work into the visualization tools so
that biologists can get their raw data, take it through this workflow, and start to
look at the genes of interest and understand the biology of the methylomes.
I like these plots in the middle here.
There's PBMCs on the left where the rows are the different cell types, and then
brain on the right. And the blue are these hypomethylated regions.
And you can see there's high cell type specificity, and these black boxes are
the differentially methylated regions that were called.
So it's a really nice way to visualize and interact with the data.
And I think it's really important to be able to develop those tools to really allow
the biologists to really be digging into the data.
Using AMETHYST and SKI-MAPv3,
I'm going to touch on a vignette here.
And I mentioned non-CG methylation is not present in most cell types.
That's true, except in neurons. So I know this is a cancer meeting, but
this is a cool vignette where
seminal work by Joe Ecker showed that when you're born, your neurons, you actually
don't have any of this non-CG methylation, but through the first several years
of life up to adolescence, it actually accumulates in your neurons.
So it's this postnatal maturation of your neurons during
this peak window of synaptogenesis.
And we really wanted to study this.
So in mice, this corresponds to P7 to P28.
So we took these regions in the mouse brain, five microdissected regions, sorted
for neurons and profiled them using our SKI-MAPv3
technology. And we were able to produce this really comprehensive
atlas of postnatal neuronal maturation.
So this is about 240,000 high-coverage single-cell methylomes,
where we're able to show all of these branching lineages of early
neurons and then differentiating out into these very specific
neuronal subtypes.
And just a vignette that I think highlights how you can use this single-cell
methylation data that's applicable across all sorts of tissue types and
certainly cancer, where there's a lot of evolution in cell state dynamics.
As an example of looking at the pseudo temporal ordering of the progression of
methylomes in this branch from MGE-derived
GABAergic neurons. So these are inhibitory neurons
branching either into parvalbumin or somatostatin.
And you can see here's a couple genes here where in the
parvalbumin branch, we're getting dramatic increase in methylation as we go through
pseudoage.With a lot less in somatostatin.
And conversely, here at this gene, we get a clear
hypomethylated window that is not the case in progressive increasing in
methylation in the other branch. So you get clear branch-specific
methylation patterns. And these concepts can be applied across any dynamic
system.
And we have lots of other kind of really novel, exciting discoveries in this that
really get into the neuroscience, but I'll leave that for those of you that are
interested in neuroscience and can look up the preprint, which will be coming out
hopefully in the next few weeks or so.
So finally, I wanted to touch on how we've taken this to the multi-omics space.
So we have our
process for doing our nucleosome disruption and taking it through combinatorial
indexing with tagmentation for single-cell whole genome sequencing,
right? Well, work also by Ryan Mulqueen
showed that we can actually tack on this step.
It's almost like a freebie processing step for generating Hi-C,
which could probably be compatible with Chuck and Nick's technologies too,
I would imagine, where you add on this restriction
digest and religation, and it allows you to capture 3D chromatin
structure.
So we showed this is, again, in pancreatic cancer.
We can get our single-cell genome plus 3D chromatin,
and this is showing the 3D plots here.
And we were actually able to identify a translocation.
So this is a balanced chromosomal rearrangement.
So you can't pick it up from copy number alterations and copy number profiling, but
it's
a subclone-specific balanced translocation.
And indeed, we can apply this to methylation.
So this is actually data from a very small snippet of a very large data
set
on mouse embryo development, where we can take a single cell and look at our 3D
chromatin structure.
But we also get our whole methylome profiles, and that's what this UMAP
is looking at the methylation. And then our chimeric reads give us this
3D structure.
And where we're really driving this, the ability to look at the 3D
structure in Hi-C from single cells is low because
it's not super high coverage. But what you can do is aggregate over these
methylation clusters and really capture that.
And then lastly is coupling ATAC with methylation.
So first ATAC with whole genome.
We did this stepwise tagmentation.
So we found if you do initial tagmentation with one index complex
and then
do the nucleosome disruption, and then do another tagmentation with a
different index,
you actually get whole genome sequencing where a subset of those reads are actually
tagged with
a different index that allows you to get chromatin accessibility as well as whole
genome profiling.
And also if you use a different set of indexes, you can actually multiplex
different samples together, which is kind of nice because you often
don't want thousands of cells for a single sample when you have to sequence really
deep for whole genome sequencing.
So it allows sample multiplexing.
And
in general, though, the
copy number profiles are a little more noisy than what you would get.
I don't know if you're seeing that too, Nick, with your dual tagmentation.
Maybe not, because you're doing it where you're isolating the DNA fully after.
But we do see more noise.
And then same with the ATAC, we get a little more noise than the assay on its
own. But we can also apply this to DNA methylation, where
we're profiling
DNA methylation and ATAC from the same cells.
And this was in our
publication on the SkyMapv3 approach.
We were able to look at nice high-quality ATAC profiles for our neuronal subtypes,
as well as methylation from the same cells.
Slightly less quality for each of these compared to the assay on their own, but
still pretty good and able to do de novo analysis on each of these
modalities. But typically, we're using this in a bridging sense.
So in
new data that we're working on in collaboration with Ted Brown and Geronimo Dimja,
we're working towards a large
AML project,
where we can look at DNA methylation and ATAC. This is the co-assay.
If you analyze it for methylation, we get nice cell type separation.
Same with ATAC.
Thank you. Yeah.
Sorry.
But we can get
nice profiles for each of these modalities on their
own. And this is actually a small subset of data from human
hematopoiesis, where we've got
these different lineages that are branching out from bone marrow samples.
There's 140,000 cells, where about 8% of these are actually
done with the co-assay. So we have a subset of these cells that are actually
co-assayed and have that ATAC signal as well.
And we can use this to integrate with other unimodal ATAC
data. So it allows us to do that bridging.
And we're starting to expand this into bridging with RNA as well.
And with that, I want to thank those involved and take any questions.
A simple technical question. Will the methods work on frozen tissue, or does it
need to be fresh tissue?
What's really nice with the methylation is that
the first step is fixing cells. So it works with fresh, it works with frozen, it
works with banked fixed cells. We haven't done
FFPE yet.
But
I imagine there are ways you could certainly get it to work.
It's really robust to input, which is one of the things that's really nice about
it.
Yeah. I'm kind of fascinated by the non-CpG methylation.
Yeah.
Have you looked more broadly in your data sets?
Could things that were neural crest-derived or somehow related to the nervous
system or maybe just
other cells within tissues have non-canonical?
So there's a great study on that from Joe Ecker's group.
It's, I think, in bioRxiv. I don't know if it's published in full
yet, but they look at that. It's really, really low levels in other tissues.
I think it's hard to delineate between just off-targetMethylation.
So, the DNMTs, it's DNMT3A that does it in the
brain, and that's also active in a lot of tissues.
And if it can do non-CG methylation, chances are if it's really
active doing CG methylation, it can do some off-target
CH methylation maybe. But the levels are very, very low in other cell types,
except embryonic stem cells, where it's a very different patterning than in
the brain, and that's a cell type that's turning over, and we have no idea
what is going on with that.
So that's another area that we're starting to explore.
Okay, cool.
Andrew, really great talk.
I was wondering if you could tell us a little bit more about, I guess,
using methylation data to separate out cell types and cell states and
when you show the data on the brain, it looks beautiful, like you have very
differentiated cell types and they separate very well.
But then I think the last slide or two you showed, you can see that-
Yeah
... cell types are really close together.
You can still distinguish what they are, but there's a lot of overlap, and it's
something I think we've been struggling with a little bit too with breast cancer
type of data where it's actually quite hard to distinguish
cell types. And I was wondering any ideas why that is and-
Mm-hmm
... whereas at the RNA level, it's usually very straightforward.
And strategies, I guess,
to choose subset specific markers, do more supervised
analysis or...
Yeah, absolutely.
So a couple things. One, in the brain, we can leverage that CH methylation,
which is a really, really powerful high information content kind of
modality. It's almost like a separate modality.
With CG specific cell types, yeah, it's more challenging.
In this one,
this is a progression. This is actually not the most up-to-date
UMAP, and we actually have more sequencing on these cells
now. And it separates a bit better.
But we do expect a continuum in this
context. And we are capturing what we expect.
But yeah, it's definitely challenging.
I think
a couple things. One, we need to get better at some of the
computational tools to address this.
A tool like MethScan I think we've seen works really well.
We have our AMETHYST tool, but the dimensionality reduction is just one
small step, and we actually encourage people to use a variety of tools to see what
works best with their data.
But I think there's more that can be
pushed forward in that space.
And it is relatively sparse data, so
accommodating that I think is important.
And then, yeah, doing the cell typing,
I know that's a challenge.
One of the challenges there is that a lot of the genes that are great marker genes
for RNA might not be great marker genes for methylation.
And the best strategy I have is look at the
genes that define the lineage
and if they're lineage-defining as opposed to where
that gene gets maybe
activated earlier on in the lineage specification.
Those tend to be more indicative.
But it's a variety of factors. But yeah, it's more challenging.
It's a newer modality. I remember going through all these headaches with
single-cell ATAC-seq when that was new.
But now that's much more straightforward, and I think we're moving towards that
now.
Thanks.
You mentioned that the front end of this is the 10X
ATAC-seq
technology, which is incorporated into their multi-ome
technology where you get ATAC-seq plus expression.
I'm wondering if you've been able to do expression plus
methylation at the single-cell level.
Yeah. So we have some
ways where we're working towards that.
To get it to work with the multi-ome, there's potentially ways to do
that. One of the challenges, doing the nucleosome disruption well
can
really ruin your RNA.
So you have to find a balance there.
There's the Peterson's, the DEFENSEQ, they do that with
RNA and
whole genome where they capture that co-assay where they do a nucleosome
disruption. It's one of the other ones that we had worked on a long time ago,
and it's trickier, but it's possible.
The one we like to use for methylation, it tends to destroy the
RNA, so it's not really compatible with something like the multi-ome kit.
But it is compatible with the combinatorial indexing.
If we have some upfront processing of the RNA in certain
ways, we can retain it. So we're working towards that, and we do have some
datasets where we have it, but it's not as robust as we would like right
now.
Thank you.
Thanks.
All right. Thanks, everyone. Let's give the speakers another round of applause.
And that ends our session. If there are any extra questions, just come up here and
talk to us. Thanks.